Antes de entrar en los sustancial del álgebra,
quiero citar una frase de una de las mentes
más brillantes de toda la historia de la
humanidad, Galileo Galilei.
Y la frase dice:
La filosofía está escrita en ese grandísimo libro abierto ante nuestros ojos; quiero decir, el universo;
pero no se puede entender si antes no
aprendemos su lenguaje y distinguimos
los símbolos en el que esta escrito. Este libro esta escrito en el lenguaje de las matemáticas...
sin las cuales uno deambula vanamente
en un oscuro laberinto.
Es una frase muy dramática y muy profunda y ese es el punto de las matemáticas.
Veremos cómo ahora que empecemos a
adentrarnos en el álgebra
y a medida que vayamos profundizando
en las matemáticas y nos permitirán aplicarlas
a ciencias como la economía, la física, la química...
pero en su esencia son ellas mismas y son más puras y profundas que sus aplicaciones.
Pero para observar a lo que me estoy refiriendo,
para ir a la raíz de esta idea,
ahora vayamos a algo muy concreto, a algo muy simple.
El ejemplo que voy a plantear, pues es muy simple.
Imaginemos que estamos en una tienda
y que hay una oferta,
pero en esta oferta, nos están ofreciendo que hay un descuento del 30%
y digamos que voy a comprar unos pantalones... bueno, yo normalmente no voy a tiendas muy sofisticadas...
y que antes de la oferta los pantalones que estoy buscando cuestan 20 pesos...
bueno, normalmente es más o menos de
los que yo compro...
así que estoy interesado en unos
pantalones de 20 pesos
y además hay una oferta de 30% de descuento sobre el precio de estos pantalones
y también me hace pensar, en cuanto pagaré
menos en la compra de estos pantalones,
pero este es un problema de álgebra.
Y así puedes decir que tu descuento es...y lo vamos a escribir así, es el 30% multiplicado por los 20 pesos,
los 20 vamos a escribirlo en morado y también podríamos expresarlo de manera decimal, o sea,
decir que esto es .30 multiplicado por los 20 pesos y bueno, si hacen las multiplicaciones esto nos da 6.
Nada demasiado especial en este caso, pero
¿qué pasa si yo quisiera generalizarlo?
Es decir, no solo el descuento,
en este par de pantalones, sino en
cualquier producto de la tienda.
Así que lo voy a escribir aquí, y podría
yo decir, sea "x" el precio que voy a pagar
por cualquier producto antes del descuento,
sin descuento del producto en la tienda
y entonces vamos a decir que el descuento es
igual a 30% veces "x",
sí, 30% veces "x" o si lo queremos escribir como decimal, pues será igual a 0.30 veces "x".
Y esto se pone interesante, porque ahora me
puedes dar el precio de cualquier producto
en la tienda, yo lo sustituyo por "x", lo
multiplico por .30 y obtengo el descuento
y empezamos a adentrarnos poco a poco al pensamiento abstracto al  del álgebra,
e iremos matizando y profundizando en conceptos más bellos y más sofisticados
a medida que estudiemos, ideas algebraicas.
Y por lo pronto, ya acabamos con este ejemplo,
ya hicimos una generalización y ya encontramos
una relación que por ejemplo, si yo tomara
un producto de 10 pesos,
pues el descuento sería .3 por 10, que es 3.
De la misma manera que para uno de 100 pesos,
pues el descuento será 30, pero vamos a
generalizar esto aún más.
Y ahora vamos a pensar en esto,
¿cuál sería el precio para cualquier descuento?
y veamos ¿cuál va a ser el descuento?
Esto... vamos a definir una variable,
voy a decir, sea "m"...
no, mejor... sea "p"...
sea "p" el porcentaje, el porcentaje de descuento...
y entonces diremos que el descuento... el descuento va a ser igual al porcentaje de descuento...
va a ser igual al porcentaje de descuento veces el precio, sí, el precio del producto antes del descuento...
o sea, el descuento va a ser igual al porcentaje
de descuento veces "x".
Y que interesante, ahora tenemos una fórmula
general que nos permite calcular cualquier
descuento, para cualquier porcentaje de oferta
y cualquier precio "x".
Y no teníamos que usar estas letras, por ejemplo, podríamos haber dicho que sea "y" igual al descuento
y en vez de escribirlo como descuento podríamos decir,
"y" será igual al porcentaje de descuento
veces el precio del producto...
sí, el precio del producto antes del descuento...
y como se puede observar, bueno,
en vez de "y"podríamos utilizar cualquier símbolo,
cualquier letra griega, siempre y cuando no
perdamos de vista que estamos
hablando del descuento.
Y las cosas siguen poniéndose muy interesantes,
porque podemos utilizar este tipo de ecuación...
sí, lo que tenemos aquí es una ecuación... lo que tenemos aquí es a lo que le llamamos una ecuación
y podemos utilizarla para cosas que no tienen nada que ver, ni con tiendas, ni con descuentos
.
Por ejemplo, en física, sabemos que la fuerza es igual a la masa por la aceleración
y estas dos cosas que están aquí tienen diferentes letras, pero es la misma idea
y podríamos decir que "y" sea la fuerza
y que "p" sea "m"...  no, no, ok...
que "p" sea la masa y claro, esto no haría
las cosas muy intuitivas, pero es la misma relación,
es la misma idea, es la misma relación.
La misma idea que se está aplicando a dos cosas totalmente diferentes
y podríamos seguir diciendo, ahora
que "x" sea la aceleración
y ahora la famosa relación para la fuerza, la podríamos escribir como que "f" que en este caso va a ser "y",
va a ser igual a la masa que estamos utilizando a "p" veces la aceleración que estamos utilizando "x".
Y ésta es exactamente la misma ecuación
y entonces podemos tomar esta ecuación y utilizarla
en la economía, en las finanzas,
o en las ciencias de la computación...
o en la lógica, o en la ingeniería mecánica,
o bueno, puedes ver, hay infinidad
de aplicaciones de esta ecuación.
Y lo que es maravilloso de las matemáticas
y del álgebra, es que podemos establecer
estas relaciones y manipularlas y después aplicarlas a esta infinidad de aplicaciones que aquí tenemos.
Y algo maravilloso también, es que nos
está dando una estructura,
una estructura profunda de como funciona el universo y estas aplicaciones humanas.
Y por ejemplo, si dijéramos, observa, "y" es igual a "px"
y otra persona dijera, ésta es "y"
y la otra persona dijera, ésta es "px",
podríamos decir...
bueno, los dos tienen la misma cosa,
los dos tienen lo mismo...
y si yo dividiera un lado, bueno, pues dividiría también el del otro lado, lo dividiría por el mismo número.
Y por ejemplo, bueno, ya sabemos
que "y" es igual a "px",
¿y qué pasaría si yo quisiera saber
cuánto es "y" entre "x"?
Bueno, pues será "px" dividido entre "x".
Y aquí es importante observar, que si yo
a algo lo multiplico y lo divido entre el
mismo número, pues voy a obtener el número original.
Por ejemplo, si yo tomo "p" y lo multiplico
por 5 y lo divido entre 5, pues me queda "p".
Así que en este caso se cancelan.
Y estamos manipulando abstracciones
y entonces tendría "y" entre "x"...
a ver, déjame escribirlo mejor...
"y" entre "x" es igual a "p"...
y ahora esto tiene implicaciones en todas estas ideas,
lo que nos está diciendo, tiene que ver con la naturaleza del universo y con todas estas actividades
y planteamos modelos y regresamos y los volvemos a aplicar en estas actividades.
Y el número de aplicaciones será infinito,
y no las conocemos todas,
iremos descubriéndolo a través de los miles de años.
Y con suerte, esto te dará una idea de porque
Galileo dijo lo que dijo,
que las matemáticas es el lenguaje que nos permitirá conocer la filosofía del universo.
Y esta también es la razón por la cual,
ciertas gentes piensan que si encontráramos
vida extraterrestre, las matemáticas serían una base para empezar a establecer una comunicación.